et la justice ordonne le déblocage de la
fonderie de bretagne à caudan morbihan
occupé depuis cinq semaines par 150
salariés grévistes
le tribunal de lorient demande la levée
des entraves à la libre circulation sur
le site est interdit à toute personne de
gêner l'accès sous peine d'expulsion
la justice a donc donné raison à la
direction de renault on le rappelle une
partie des stars et il s'oppose à la
vente de l'usiné annoncée le 11 mars par
un groupe automobile français
on en parle tout de suite avec un train
vitae mais le golf il est délégué
syndical cgt de la fonderie de bretagne
bonjour merci d'être à coup alors
comment a été accueilli la décision la
justice d'ordonner le déblocage de
l'usiné
bon la décision n'est pas surprenante
c'est ce n'était pas un vrai blocage
ainsi une grève que l'on mène depuis le
27 avril la décision tombe le 1er juin
renault a mis du temps à se décider
c'est ça c'est incompréhensible c'est au
niveau de hauts niveaux de défaites que
renault ne s'occupe de nous depuis
maintenant six semaines
on est plutôt sur un blocage de dialogue
avec eux dialogue bloqué ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il n'ya pas il n'ya plus
pourparlers en cours
ben vous avez rencontré nous à cesson
sévigné et maya maintenant 15 jours et
s'est engagé à revenir vers nous et sont
toujours pas revenus
maintenant on sait que des discussions
se passent un haut niveau ça devient un
problème national
au delà de la revue d'art du stratégique
qui a été menée ici on se rende compte
que renault n'a aucun argument pour
abandonner font ils bretagne c'était une
erreur stratégique et nos erreurs
économiques et au delà de ça la
stratégie industrielle de renault est
remise en question si même au niveau du
gouvernement via un médiateur qui a été
nommé par l'état
mais ce médiateur là j'ai eu encore au
téléphone n'est pas plus ou moins d'une
heure il n'a aucune nouvelle de renault
aussi de son côté ils essaient de les
contacter et aucun comté alors comment
on va s'organiser aujourd'hui la suite
de votre mobilisation aux vues
la décision de justice la mobilisation
est là elle va rester à les renforcer
les salariés sont déterminés à rester en
groupe renault les salariés sont
déterminés à garder leur emploi et les
salariés sont déterminés à préparer
l'avenir sur le site de fans et de
bretagne donc on va continuer la grève
est sous une autre façon de le faire
c'est à dire mais rester devant
l'entreprise sans empêcher l'accès mais
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
la direction cévaër qui va faire tourner
l'entreprise les salariés qui sont en
grèce ce sont les séries productif donc
sans nul doute que rien alors vous
pouvez nous rappeler précisément toutes
les revendications aujourd'hui est ce qu
elles sont les mêmes que celles d'il ya
cinq semaines
tout à fait c'est la montée en vin en
volume c'est à dire que là on bossait
sur dix neuf mille cinq cents tonnes à
l'année
on était à bosser car en 1 8 nous ce
qu'on veut c'est travailler en
trois-huit du lundi matin 6 heures au
samedi matin 6 heures c'est avoir un
plan de charge et un montée du plan de
charge s'est récemment groupe renault et
c'est préparer l'avenir avec une pièce
maîtresse ce qu'est le portugais avait
que l'aluminium mais le goff
merci en tout cas d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et d'avoir et en direct avec
nous sur rt franc je rappelle que vous
êtes est délégué syndical cgt de la
fonderie de bretagne merci f